it is time for drew's news your good
news machete for cutting your way
through the thick forest news
and with me at the desk is my favorite
co-pilot ross matthews hi everybody
well it's women's history month and
we're starting with a phenomenal woman
who is very near and dear to this show
gail king pop sugar just published
gail's thoughts on why it's not so bad
to put yourself first she says that
girls are raised to take care of
everyone else before themselves and it
took her many years all the way up to
her divorce to realize selfishness can
be a positive not just a negative and it
is vital to prioritize yourself and gail
says quote when you're happy with
yourself when you're happy with the job
you're doing you're a better person
period and this makes you a better
employee which means you're certainly a
better mother which means you're
certainly a better friend the gospel
according to gail
right
if darryl king says it
she's about to read the full essay go on
pop sugar now i love this i do too you
know you think about whenever you talk
to somebody um who's maybe
later in their life and you say what
would you tell a younger version of
yourself it's always to take it easy on
myself to be kinder to myself to love
myself sooner and i just i can't agree
with gail moore the sooner you can do a
little self-care and just nurture
yourself the better person oh i just
struggle with the oxygen mask
oh that analogy i that analogy never
does it for me i'm like we're not always
like in a plane crash scenario i need
like a daily
metaphor that isn't so severe and
intense like the oxygen mask and then
self-care is a term that just feels too
passive it doesn't have that fight in it
um i'm terrible at those things but
i like how she's not talking about
necessarily pampering yourself it's just
prioritizing yourself well yeah and i
think you have to love yourself and
that's how you prioritize yourself
synonymous with self-care can also be
self-awareness and not the ego kind but
the knowing what you need to take care
of others because i love taking care of
others i'm really good at it you are not
as great prioritizing myself so read the
full article on pop sugar and see what
gail has to say thanks gail thank you we
love you
all right
we also love it is design week around
here so let's talk about where pop
culture something we love oh i love it
meets home decor something else we love
we've already talked on the show here
about how bridgerton is inspiring
interior design oh we love bridgertown
oh my god season two is coming out soon
like any second i know i can't wait it's
crowning
oh i'm so proud of you is that a double
pie yeah that is a double pun wow drew
well okay we hear there are other shows
that are inspiring design out there
people apartment therapy reports an
analysis of search data from the last
year found one big show people are
inspired by is the show sherlock people
are loving that victorian furnishing
that they call it clutter core design
which is more is more kind of approach
cramming your space with vintage
accessories and trinkets that causes
anxiety for me too much too much
um that's true you love a white box
rossi i do i i love the interior design
of mad men they say that one was a big
influence as well very mid-century yes
and now people are turning to friends
for that 90s design aesthetic
and i started thinking like what am i
into now what's inspiring my design that
i'm watching and i watch just the worst
i'm you know i watched a 90-day fiance
johnny fiance i watch i was thinking
like what is my design a second inspired
by those those little pods and love is
blind
i kind of want my own pod now
um fun fact
the kitchen here the way i designed it
with tom and mel are production
designers um i was inspired by the
handmaid's tale kitchen
oh my gosh it's so all the shaker style
that that show had if you think of the
handmaid's tale kitchen and you look at
our kitchen it might be like oh right
[Music]